This is iPhone 10 not X
10 not to be confused with DMX Xbox one X or OS X which is actually OS 10 oh, wait
You say what happened to nine
With an all-new edge-to-edge 5.8. Inch OLED super retina HDR display
This is iPhone 10
It's 10 because it's the 10th anniversary of the first iPhone. [Steve Jobs]: "Today Apple is going to reinvent the phone".
Ten years ago Steve Jobs introduced the first iPhone on stage at Macworld 2007 and I was there
I am standing right in front of the iPhone
Spinning around shortly, and you'll be able to see the front of it
I saw it in person inside the spinning glass display and little did I know at the time that this phone would change my life
not just mine
Everyone's, this was the start of creating simplified apps social networking and laying the groundwork for new forms of communicating like iMessage and FaceTime
It put the world and our friends in the palm of our hand like usual and typical Apple fashion
They may not have been the first to make a smartphone, but they revolutionized
simplified and made it desirable and mainstream
I can promise you that I will never be the first person in line for any sort of Apple event
There's no way, this is it like we're here. We're first
This year was special Apple announced the new iPhone 10 at the Steve Jobs theater at their new Apple park campus
This was the first event that they had ever held there
And it was a beautiful reminder of what Steve Jobs started 10 years ago with the first original iPhone
[Tim Cook]: "And it was only fitting that Steve should open his theater".
Remember a time back in my day when you couldn't even copy and paste on the first iOS
What is that what apps you got there? That's nice
You've got your Wi-Fi on so what's new with iPhone 10 you asked
It's got Face ID
Instead of using Touch ID because there's no longer a home button on the iPhone 10 you use your face to unlock your phone
Hopefully you weren't too attached to that Touch ID because your face is now the replacement
With the full front edge to edge OLED screen sacrifices had to be made
It's actually quite shocking how fast Face ID works it just works. It's hard to explain. It just works
Setup is super simple. You just roll your face around following the on-screen directions, and there you go
This is all made possible with the new
TrueDepth camera it projects and analyzes more than 30,000 invisible dots on your face to create a very very
Very precise map your face is now registered for logging in and face pay
Yes, face pay just double click the side button and just as you would with Touch ID Apple Pay pops up
And I just bought a cheese will that looks like a pumpkin with my face
It's so great like I just paid with my face
But what if I'm wearing a hat or glasses or I get old or get Botox?
I'm not quite sure but Apple has promised us that it will learn your face as you change whatever that means
Privacy is obviously a huge concern for most people and if it's not then you should really rethink your priorities with face
ID'd there's a one in a million chances of a stranger unlocking your phone randomly whereas with touch ID it's 1 in
50,000 of course if you have an identical twin, then those chances are a little bit higher
I don't have a twin and all the twins that I know were unavailable to help me with this day
I've seen I'd love to help you, but I'm trying to win Dancing with the Stars right now and Jonathan
He's busy bench-pressing kitchens. Here is mine on twin sister
She can't get into my phone using her face even though people say we look alike, but I don't really see it
Now what did she chases me around and tries to use my face to gain access into my phone even though
I don't want her to this scenario. I'm sure will be replicated if someone refuses to unlock their phone for you
There is an extra layer of protection to avoid this from happening by turning on attention awareness
It'll only unlock your phone when you're looking at it
This will also be used in some apps so that they'll know that you're actually looking at your phone and avoid dimming the screen from
Inactivity if you're still not sold on face ID that's okay
You can still opt to use just the good old fashioned passcode all this talk of face ID and removal of the home button justine
how do we do things using the same familiar gestures in iOS will get you around your new iphone 10 just fine a
Simple swipe up and you're back to the home screen
Swipe down in the top right corner for access to your control center to get to your notifications
You can swipe down on the left or you can swipe down right here on the top swipe up in paws to show your current
Open apps press and hold on those open apps to delete you can swipe up or you can press this little delete button to remove
them you can also access these by swiping left and right at the very bottom of your screen you can also use hey Siri if
You have that turned on just by saying hey Siri that will activate Siri on your iPhone. No stop it
I'm recording vo Siri the on button is now a dedicated Siri button press and hold to ask Siri a question
I ever tell you that I actually met the voice of Siri
Some of you may already know this, but if you don't this is Susan Bennett the voice of Siri
What's your favorite staple all my favorite phrases? I don't know and I don't care
To turn off your iPhone 10 you hold the power button and the volume button down you can also turn it off in the software
In iOS 11, which I actually had no idea about until finding it right now
So take a screenshot you hold the power and the volume up button
Magically with these screenshots the notch does not appear
what kind of sorcery is this one of the things that I've been looking forward to forever is wireless charging both the iPhone 10 and
The iPhone 8 are embedded with Qi wireless charging, and it has an all-new glass back
this is by far the strongest glass that Apple has ever implemented in their phones both on the front display and the back I
Definitely don't want to repeat of this this might have been my first iPhone shatter, I think
I'm not sure I've lost track with the air power out in 2018
You'll finally be able to charge all of your devices on this. This is a wireless power mat
You can charge all of your devices at the same time, and I mean it's wireless
But like it's not just no wires connected to your devices you get the point this here is the fan-favorite
Top notch this thing has so much technology packed into it an infrared camera a flood illuminator
proximity sensor ambient light sensor speakers microphones front camera and a dot projector all of this for animated emojis face ID and
Portrait mode selfies, but let's be real selfies are a thing of the past
Animated emojis that mirror your exact expressions of why you're really dropping on the new iPhone 10
You can record up to 10 second an emoji videos and text them to your friends. Hey Jenna
Another thing that I really like about the in emojis is if you don't want to send a video you can
Actually turn it into a sticker so all I have to do is instead of hitting record
I just make an emotion and click it can I drag and drop?
Just like you would do an iMessage sticker
Much like the portrait mode that you may be familiar with you can now use the front facing camera with new portrait lighting modes
natural light studio light contour light stage light and stage light mono
I'm not really sure if this is considered hashtag no filter, but come on
We all know those hashtag no filter photos have been retouched and edited color corrected face tune face blurred beyond recognition
But hey I did not a filter, right
One of the biggest physical changes and main identifiers to say hey guys guess what I have the new iPhone 10 is the rear dual
cameras they've now been rotated vertically with a quad tone LED flash right in the center so that everyone will know that you have the
Newest iPhone you can also let them know when they ask about your new phone that it has a larger and faster 12
megapixel sensor with improved optical image stabilization and new on the iPhone 10
optical image stabilization on both lenses a new iPhone 10 features the brand new a 11 Bionic chip that is currently the most powerful and
Smartest chip in a smartphone with the for efficiency cores and the new CPU it'll be about 70 percent faster than the previous 810 fusion
And the two performance scores are up to 25% faster
Did I lose you it's okay make yourself some flashcards
So you'll have these details ready for a salty Android user and I'm not hating
I've had plenty of Android phones in my days
I just want you to have the facts ready one of the things that I just couldn't get over is how?
Beautiful the new screen is it has a million to 1 contrast ratio with the best color
Accuracy of any previous iPhone they've also increased the speakers by 35%
And they're in stereo this will make binge watching an entire Netflix series a little bit more enjoyable
I don't usually have the true tone display
Turned on but depending upon your current lighting situation your displays colors will shift to give you the most accurate
Representation of what you're looking at it's pretty easy to switch on and off so if you find yourself looking at your screen and wondering
Why it's turning a little bit?
Too yellow or a little bit too blue that could be the issue another of the things that I'm loving so much about this new
Phone is the video options now with the iPhone 8 and the iPhone 10
You can shoot 4k 60 frames a second and up to
240 frames a second at 1080p so what that means for most people is that you're probably going to eat up a ton of storage
Really really really quick, but what that means for making cool high quality videos you can do that right from your iPhone
And if you're new to my channel welcome, I'm a sucker for slo-mo with the new optical image stabilization
You'll see a noticeable difference in low-light photos
New and iOS 11 you can loop bounce and create long exposure shots from your live photos also with the back vertical cameras this placement
Is so much better aligned for depth sensing, which means increase spatial awareness for augmented reality?
I haven't got a chance to spend much time with any AR apps
but the few that I have a tried are a lot of fun with all of these new integrations in the latest iPhone 10 and
the iPhone 8
I'm really looking forward to seeing what developers are working on with AR kit, so that's the new iPhone 10
It comes in space gray and silver with storage options of why even bother 64 gigs and oh my gosh
I shoot a lot of holes hey video in photos of white dog
256 gigs leave me some comments below and let me know what your favorite iPhone can feature is
Thank you guys so much for watching. I will see you in my next video
Thank you guys so much for watching. I hope you enjoyed this video
I had so much fun making it for you. If you liked it make sure you hit like and don't forget to subscribe
wink can an emojis wink